Hi, there's Steve Kaufmann here,
and today I wanna talk again about
basics and explain why we didn't
bother trying to master the basics
of the language we're learning.
I talked a bit about the basics
last time, or in a previous video.
I explained that there is sort of
a, a theory which I, uh, basically,
uh, subscribe to, and that is that
different aspects of the language,
we're gonna learn them in a certain.
to some extent it depends on
what our native language is.
It depends on the language we're learning.
It depends on what kind of
content we're exposing ourselves
to, but we can't force it.
Things will fall into place
when they fall into place.
So don't worry about the basics, don't
worry about, you know, when you're
quite well along in the language and
there's still certain basic terms or
basic structures that you get wrong.
Uh, don't try to, you know, force the
pace by learning the basics up front.
I, I think it's a futile exercise.
And so I want to get
into more detail on this.
First of all, what are the basics?
If I Google, uh, you know, the basics.
The basics of Spanish, the
basics of French, the basics of
Russian, of Chinese, of Japanese.
There's all kinds of pages on the
internet, which will give you various
versions of what the basics are.
They could be basic vocabulary and some
will say, you know, you gotta learn
the numbers and you gotta learn the
colors and the names of the months.
And all of these things are very, or names
of different, you know, food products.
All of these things are
very difficult to remember.
I find that numbers and colors take
a long time before they sink in and,
and studying a list of numbers or
days of the month, uh, or excuse me,
of months, et cetera, names of the
months is, is not gonna help you.
You have to kind of learn them
gradually as you're exposing
yourself to more and more input.
Some people say the basics are,
you know, hello, how are you?
My name is...
Those kinds of phrases,
greetings and so forth.
But a lot of these things you're gonna
learn fairly soon in the process anyway.
One of the reasons why we designed
our mini stories at LingQ with
high frequency verbs is because we
need verbs and high frequency verbs
are quite important for speaking.
Those are the ones we're going
to use when we start to speak.
And in the mini stories, there's
a lot of repetition uh, in each
story of high frequency verbs and a
across the story, there's a lot of
repetition of high frequency verbs.
I, I even went to a ChatGPT I asked,
what are the basics in Spanish?
They gave me a list of 10 things,
uh, one of which was wrong.
You know, it says, okay, word order
in Spanish is subject-verb-object.
Again, we're gonna very quickly
discover the verb object.
We can look at it ahead of time as part
of an overview of the language, but
very soon, if we're exposing ourselves
to content, and I, as you know, I
recommend our mini stories at LingQ.
You're gonna come across that it's
gonna seem natural to you that that's
how they do things in that language.
Over time, it'll become
the dominant pattern.
Gender, Spanish nouns have a
gender, masculine or feminine.
Yeah, you learn that pretty quickly.
That doesn't mean you know
which nouns are which gender.
Uh, five, of course, Ser and the estar,
uh, is, is this aspect, basic, call
it basic in Spanish, that the verb
to be can either temporary status
or a permanent status, but there's
a fair amount of subjectivity there.
And the interesting thing about Ser
and estar is you can get it wrong
and it doesn't hinder communication.
So to what extent is that basic
to comprehension or communication?
I don't think it's that important.
I think we gradually
get more and more used.
Uh, ChatGPT also told me that personal
subject pronouns, Spanish has personal
subject pronouns such as ...which must
be used in conjunction with verbs.
That, of course, is not true because in
Spain, in Spanish, the verbs conjugate.
The endings change.
So very often you can tell which
person that is without having
to use the personal pronoun.
But that's ChatGPT.
That's not necessarily
an authoritative source.
Um, but then you can go to, I went to
another source and here are the basic,
you know, topics of grammar for French.
And it has terms in here, like
aspects, habitual perfective,
imperfection, mood indicative,
imperative, conditional subjunctive.
Uh, you know, if you try to learn that
upfront, uh, you know, conjunctions,
coordinating conjunctions,
subordinating conjunctions.
I just think it would be very
difficult to learn that upfront.
So I don't think you can learn
basic vocabulary upfront.
I don't think you can learn
the basic structures upfront.
I think, as I've said many times,
language learning comes down to the
three keys that, again, I can't remember
her name, but the lady who ran the,
uh, San Diego State, uh, Language
Department said it's all about your
attitude, the time you spend with the
language and your ability to notice.
And so attitude is very important.
Of course, we want to improve.
Uh, I'm not suggesting we should
ignore, uh, correct, correct usage.
I mean, this depends as well,
but obviously we have a model of
the language that we would like
to get as close as possible to.
So we want to be constantly
improving, constantly getting close
to this model of the language.
Now it could be Brazilian usage in
Portuguese or usage in Portugal.
It could be usage in Quebec
for French or usage in France.
It could be, um, usage in Taiwan
for Chinese or usage in Beijing.
We have a model of the language which
we like, and, and the more we like it,
the more we're likely to imitate it.
Imitation is the highest form of flattery.
We want to get closer to that usage,
and so we start to notice more things.
The more we listen, the
more things we notice.
Things that we don't notice at
first, we will notice them later on.
The idea and, and so I think there was a
sort of pushback from some people saying,
you know, how can you ignore the basics?
Uh uh, we have to have the basics,
or we can't speak correctly.
That's not true.
I have tried mastering tables, you
know, declension tables in German
and so forth, and it didn't work.
It was only when I got into more and
more listening and reading, exposed my,
exposing myself to the language that
some of these things started to slot in.
So we have to have an attitude
of wanting to improve.
If we don't want to
improve, we won't notice.
So even in those three keys, obviously
attitude affects the other two.
If you like the language, you're
gonna spend time with the language.
If you like the language and you want
to notice things in the language,
you'll notice more things in the
language, whether that be pronunciation
or usage or whatever it may be.
Something like the subjunctive, I don't
think we notice it at first, but in
time, if we're motivated, if we like
the language, if we're hearing someone
speak the language in a way that we like
and we want to imitate, we're going to
imitate the subjunctive, but not using the
subjunctive doesn't hinder communication.
So it's not a basic, in the sense
that it prevents communication.
It is a basic in the sense that we
would like to get as close as possible
to this model of usage that we have.
Uh, so I, I just wanted to sort
of follow up on my previous video.
I didn't wanna suggest that we don't
want to speak, you know, correctly,
or we don't want to, you know, imitate
certain standard patterns of usage.
I think every serious language learner
wants to do that, but achieving that
will depend on having an attitude
that I like the language, I enjoy
the language, I enjoy learning.
I want to get better.
I want to get closer to
that standard of usage.
I'm willing to put in the time.
There are no shortcuts.
It's not as if we can learn a formula.
This is how the language works,
now we're going to be able to
learn the language more quickly.
I don't believe that we can have an
overview if we want, where it tells us
that this language is subject-verb-object
or subjec-object-verb, sort of
an abstract of the language.
I'm not sure that helps very much.
Either we don't understand what that
overview actually is saying or we
will in any case, as with so many
of these sort of basic vocabulary
items, basic structures, we will
eventually get those through a program
of sustained listening and reading.
So, uh, because there was a
certain amount of pushback on this
idea of, of avoiding the basics
uh, I thought I would follow up
with another video on the subject.
By the way, with reference to
ChatGPT I am looking at it.
I don't know yet where that fits into
my language learning routine or possibly
with, with LingQ, I'm going to be doing
a video, uh, uh, interview with Luca
Lampariello, and I think we may even
discuss that subject a little bit.
So thank you for listening.
Bye for now.